welcome to the first annual wrists of
fury foosball tournament at moon tower
comedy festival
the winner of the tournament then faces
this champion right here kelsey cook
like lin-manuel miranda she's not
throwing away her shot let's face it
dude i would argue this is more of a
sport than nascar that's right everyone
can drive not everyone can fuse i don't
want to say dan soder is high but he
said it's so nice to be here at south by
southwest
dude i suck so bad at foosball you do
you literally do josh is bitter because
he just lost to me and risk of fury a
couple days ago i scored two goals on
you how did that go though in the end i
mean i lost of course brad is going
chairless on this match ladies and
gentlemen and it's going hairless on his
balls so here we go so the losers in
these early rounds are murdered in the
back absolutely we should let people
know that again open carry in texas
they're okay with it they'll murder
anything here except for an unborn fetus
guys we're having a great time
you